hello
i'm dr greg sadler and i would like to
tell you
about a new course a very short audio
course that i
have out on the listenable platform
called
basics of stoic philosophy and
practice and i i've designed it in such
a way
that you can listen to it on the go or
while you're working out while you're
doing other things
and you can learn exactly what it's
telling you about some of the bare bones
some of the basics
about who the stoics were and what
stoicism is all about
and it can be a great refresher for
people who already know something about
stoicism
you know can provoke some some thoughts
here and there about things they might
have
overlooked or forgotten about but it's
also for people who have no background
in stoicism at all but have heard about
it and want to understand
why hundreds of thousands of people
across the world
are studying and practicing stoicism
as a philosophy of life i'm going to
tell you about the course in just a
minute but before that
i want to say a little bit about
listenable as
a platform so what listenable offers
are audio courses that have
a number of lessons and the lessons are
anywhere from about 3 to 10 minutes long
so they're nice and short
you can listen to them sequentially you
can jump around in a course you can
focus in
on the topics that you are most
interested in you can go back to it over
and over again
and re-listen to any of the
courses that you want to and listenable
has a huge
range of material out there i've been
exploring it because they
gave me a like a 30-day trial thing for
creating a course and
you know there's there's quite a lot of
interesting content
they approached me because they they
knew i had the video channel
and the sadler's lecture podcast and
said would you like to do a course for
us
and i thought yeah i'll give it a shot
let's see how this goes
and you know i was very impressed by
their insistence
on producing really high quality
audio you know you have to record it all
in one
session so that it there's a consistency
of sound in the sound space that you
have
you write out scripts ahead of time
which is something kind of new
for me a new set of skills that i had to
develop but also good for thinking about
what you want to say
usually i'm actually just going as i am
right here
without any any major notes and just
talking directly to an audience but i
think there's something good about that
so i'm really excited to have this
course out i'm already plotting out my
next course
which will be on plato's symposium that
i will be developing for listenable so
let's talk about this course
what does the basics of stoic philosophy
and practice have
i've got a list here of the different
lessons first lesson just an
introduction of the class telling you
what we're going to be doing a little
bit about stoicism and
why it matters the second one is about
stoicism
uppercase s versus stoic stoicism
lowercase s a really important
distinction
something that many people are confused
about
and clarifying that we're going to be
doing the uppercase s
actual genuine stoic philosophy and
practices
the third lesson introduces you to some
of the main
uh thinkers writers practitioners of
stoicism
in the ancient times the people that
modern stoix themselves
are drawing upon then we jump right into
some
nuts and bolts core concepts we
focus on the stoic conception of
happiness or eudaimonia what is that
what are the stoics actually about what
is the
central goal for studying stoic
philosophy and
practicing it and applying it then we
talk about the good
the bad and this vast range of things
the stoics called the indifference this
is a key
idea of stoic ethical theory we talk
about a
very important concept the dichotomy of
control
the things we actually have control over
the things that we don't how to make
that distinction
what happens what goes right for us when
we do make that distinction properly
how we screw ourselves up when we we
don't then we jump into talking about
the four
cardinal virtues another really central
aspect to stoicism
what is wisdom what is justice what is
courage
what is temperance some people ask
questions like well i don't i don't see
kindness or gratitude in there they're
in there
you just gotta dig and that's what that
lesson is
is helping you to understand then we
delve into stoicism
and its theory of the emotions which
emotions do we want to
hold on to and prioritize like joy
love you know calmness all those sorts
of things which do we want to
try to eliminate like anger or envy or
irrational fear which of those do we
actually need to keep
but manage properly like rational fear
right
or rational desire so that's very
important
then we start looking at how stoicism
helps us to
widen our perspectives to look at
ourselves not just
as individuals but as members
of a community and extending that
community ultimately all the way out to
the cosmos thinking about things in in
space and time
we look at another really key set of
practices with examining expectations
and appearances
one of the ways in which practicing
stoicism helps us to
have a happier life is by learning to be
self-critical about the expectations
that we have
our responses to impressions and
appearances
not in a way that tears ourselves down
but in a way that allows us to live a
more
rational and grounded existence then we
move into how we rework habits and why
habits are so important what we're
aiming at
freedom and then finally we finish up by
talking about going back to the stoic
authors and talking about what text you
might want to
acquire and read and and which to start
out with i give you some
reading suggestions and i tell you why
you should check out this one
before this one so i'm really happy with
the way the course
came out the listenable people are very
happy on their end with
how the quality of the sound
and the instruction came together you
can check out the course for free
i'm going to include some links one link
is directly to the course where you can
go to it
there's already a lot of learners who
have gone through progress
through all the lessons that could be
you i'm also going to include an
affiliate link
so i do want to be very upfront about
this if you click the affiliate link and
you sign up for
for listenable i do get a little cut of
that
but it also gives you a 30 off thing
that gives you access not just to my
course but to a
whole plethora of other courses that you
might find interesting so i just wanted
to bring this to all of your attention
you can see the links below check out
the course if you think it's something
that you would like to do
go ahead and follow through and start
learning about stoicism today or if
you're already an old hand at it
do some refreshers
you